this is from michael tompkins jason i
need a wedding gift idea what's hot
right now well okay
there's a lot of different uh things you
can get people i always go with cash
hash money
uh and uh i give i always try to give a
big thick envelope of cash not even a
check
literally went to a wedding recently
and asked my wife to take out a very
large amount of money in hundies crisp
clean hundies put it in an envelope i
like you know i'm old school like in
goodfellas i like to have that fat
envelope and uh i like the idea that
somebody opens it up and they get a nice
big stack of handy so
as many hundys as you can fit if you're
like a 500 person if you're a 10 hyundy
you know a couple dime skis whatever you
can afford people do like experiences
and um
so
i i also do like the idea of getting
them plane tickets if they're into
experiences or something like that or a
hotel gift card that they can use
getting them something from a registry i
find kind of lame uh
i just never liked that i found it i
find it kind of uh what sort of gauche
is that the word for like tacky
i just don't like the idea of like going
through somebody's list from bed bath
and beyond or wherever and i'm gonna get
them the bread maker or the ice cream
maker like the spatulas
and then like i start getting ocd about
like
well the top five items have been bought
already and you know
i just give cash cash
cash money or a gift card that's what's
so nice so you can get an amazon gift
card um i like doing that i give people
amazon gift cards all the time in fact i
would get a lot of miles for my
different programs you can cash them in
for gift cards and so by around the
holidays i would just cash them in and
get 10 25 50 and 100 gift cards and i'd
have a stack of these like i'm trying
like five grand worth
and then
you know somebody who works at the house
you know gardeners or you know
uh
mailman
or male delivery person the guard the
sanitation team who pick up our garbage
just anybody who ups driver fedex driver
you have like regular drivers who come
by i just say hey thanks so much and i
just give them a 25 or 50 gift card and
man
that is amazing and then also with my
daughters the other there's another hack
whenever those people come like when the
garbage uh sanitation truck comes to
pick up our garbage
uh we my daughters would love to watch
it because you know watch the machine
pick up the thing i would have them grab
a couple of sodas they would go outside
with a couple of sodas and you know my
three daughters would be out there and
garbage uh guy would come up he's really
nice and they'd say can we offer you a
soda or two
and uh they would offer it i would just
try to teach my daughters some respect
for people who are working every day and
making our lives easier right
and so always give big tips and always
given you know a soda
you know or an iced tea or a bottle of
water or salsa or something too and i
try to do nice ones you know like be
nice to the people who are working and
you know working class heroes i was part
of that group and i always just give big
tips and i think the same goes for
weddings like people are starting their
life
give them a nice thick envelope
cash money
the best
you